joining us now is Valeria a 12 year old
she's only 7 years old please welcome 10
year old Mia on her invention the power
pony so how many of you sold over a
thousand
whoa she can already say she's a fashion
designer and a growing list of exclusive
clients okay tell you what I wasn't
doing at eight I would like to accept
you under my wing and offer you a
mentorship
we're giving you ten thousand dollars
worth of toys
like spectacular I can't even speak
right now
talk about being born to fly both of
your parents are pilots yeah that is
crazy so how did you get into this is
just watching like my dad was like pilot
and it's always been my dream to fly a
jet oh my gosh you're so cool I'm gonna
be the first Commander you're gonna be
the first Commander you aim higher don't
aim at all
major Michelle
[Applause]
I
[Applause]
I like no furniture will get in my way
you were throwing babies and children
out of your way to get to her you're
gonna come to work with me
and you're gonna be a Thunderbird for a
day
you can
actually when I went to school I wear my
hair in afro and a lot of people had a
lot of mean things to say about it and
that really surprised me because at my
other school everybody used to love it
but when I went to this school everybody
just had like several negative things to
say about it yeah yeah that's mean kids
can be mean and I have to tell her no
how did you feel this morning and she
said I felt good and I said that's all
that matters I said you're not good
your video though has inspired so many
people including my guest say hello to
Tracy Ellis Ross thank you
I saw your video and I was so moved
because your hair is an extension of
your legacy what you come from your
story and everything that you are and
your beauty just keep doing what you're
doing and just go make the world a
better place
[Applause]
this wasn't even expected I'm losing my
mind it's fine what's your Ultimate
Dream well my Ultimate Dream is
definitely to compete uh you know win
gold in the Olympics well there's
someone that I know who also believes
that you have what it takes to make it
to the Olympics and I want you to meet
her maybe so it's Tamara that's a stock
oh my God
oh no oh no
oh no oh no here we go
hilarious I am so proud of you for
everything that you are accomplishing
for going out there and making sure that
nobody stopped you you're going to get
first place
oh my gosh that's awesome all right
thank you so much it's a gold medalist
telling you you can do it you believe it
right yeah definitely our first guest
has stolen hearts on the big and small
screen now she's staring and the fox hit
9-1-1 Lone Star please welcome live
Tyler
all right I'd like you to meet Anaya
yeah isn't she amazing I'm very nine
years old I'm amazing
even how you talk though like even your
inflection on all your words is very
hosts like it's very great thank you
with a whole lot of women do you have
any questions for Luke yes when you are
nervous did you ever like when you went
on stage did you ever feel nervous all
the time I just back there said wait
what's my name Kelly
I'm here on the Kelly Clarkson show and
she's actually going to help me surprise
one of my favorite fans
hi
happy birthday to you
Chevelle yeah
[Music]
happy 10th birthday Chevelle I really am
very appreciative of you I also before I
go
did get you a birthday present so
um could could you guys bring in the
birthday present something for you to
hold on to
from me
it's my signature guitar so
you can hang it up or you can learn to
play it or whatever you want but that's
that's my thank you for your life
so you've been named a Marvel Superhero
so what exactly does that mean it's
basically a group of kids who fight
every day to make this world a better
place not just for us and not just for
our adults but also for our younger
generations and so as I get older I
learn more about the power of marching
and power of using your voice to people
like Angela Davis and John Lewis and
Martin Luther King Jr and Malcolm X I
learned that there is power in your
voice and even if you're a kid as a
younger generation as a community that
we are we will no longer silence the
oppression because in my eyes we have
already accepted it too long there are
already too many people who are scared
and Afraid and there are already too
many kids who are actually dying and I
have a quote that says when one Falls We
All Fall but when one Rises we all rise
and so in my eyes us helping our young
people is a way that we will all ride
I'm so moved by you right now I can't
even talk you are so powerful thank you
you want to sing yellow a little bit
I'll sing I'll sing with you we really
don't have to oh my gosh we do she will
die if we don't if we
so then I took mine
me too
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah I I need to too but I'm just
holding it you know what you know what's
funny is that always happens
[Music]